[Music]
hey
ladies and gentlemen yeah it's tuesday
oh yeah
tammy's in there um let's see what else
is in there
everybody's here everybody's soap's in
there
you guys just turn up to watch us
babbling every single day
that's so cute
all the regulars yeah but everybody's
well not all the regulars but a lot of
the regulars
yeah okay
watch us talking about stuff our house
smells so good right now we've made a
couple little loaves of pumpkin bread
yeah i made some pumpkin add a leftover
pumpkin from the jack-o'-lantern
yeah that we still had i had some i made
some uh pumpkin chicken curry
that was really good that [ __ ] was
delicious
but i couldn't we i made so much of it
we couldn't eat it yeah you have
you have that [ __ ] how many gallons
is that pot that you want that's about
three gallons worth of [ __ ] yeah it
could be like three
i couldn't eat it all we couldn't eat it
at all yeah and there's not enough room
to freeze it man i got my freezer just
[ __ ] packed
so it got to be about seven days old and
i'm done that's just gotta go
this is why we're fat yeah because of
all this [ __ ] food
seriously though afterwards down a
little bit no everything's in the
freezer now
yeah okay so we don't have to [ __ ]
gorge everything's in the freezer except
that pumpkin bread is
just fresh out of the oven so as soon as
we're done recording this i'm going to
go make some coffee and i'm going to
have some of that [ __ ] from a little
afternoon
[ __ ] bread freezes but there's no
room we'll refrigerate it
yeah we put we put like all kind of uh
nuts and seeds and chocolate like dark
chocolate bits and
yeah it was um what kind of it was uh
cashews chocolates cherries
yeah uh pecans and
what was it pecans or walnuts or or yeah
what the [ __ ] were those
not a pumpkin seed are those sunflower
seeds they don't look like sauces
it was good i forgot what they were
though i don't know what kind of seeds
they're some kind of seeds they're
little green seeds
green seeds it was all like big dreams
it was like a trail mix thing that we
got at sam's or something and i said
it's not in the pumpkin bread big green
seeds i forgot what kind of seeds they
were they were good
yeah yeah if somebody knows what big
green seeds are
they're like not big greens they're like
the size of a pumpkin seed
but they were green well a little bit
smaller than a plant oh yeah yeah
bethany who said made three pumpkin pies
and gave two away i still feel like a
piglet i know that feeling we made like
eight of them last year i think because
we had the big pockets i got so sick of
[ __ ] pumpkin pie but
yeah i'll never get sick of pumpkin pie
we had three jack-o'-lanterns i think
that year didn't we no two big ones two
big ones we had two big ones
yeah it made like uh eight nine gallons
worth of pumpkin puree you just can't
use it we had one of those big you know
those big [ __ ] kitty litter things
yeah no it wasn't kidding literally cat
food it was a cat food it was a big cat
it's like a 20 pound
at one time it was like a 20 pound uh
plastic
like bucket square bucket yeah like you
buy it sam's then you buy a sands where
they had cat food in it
yeah well i cleaned it out and converted
it into i use them for stuff like
store and flour and sugar and [ __ ] like
that well i had an extra one and i
put all that pumpkin puree in there put
it in the back refrigerator
i could we could eat it i was making
pumpkin bread
pumpkin pie curry pumpkin curry pumpkin
soup
cupcakes monkey cupcakes
i was even
pumpkin and persimmon cookies or
something like that yeah it was
something like that
they would have been good but we never
got around to it i don't know i just
i i only we only got through maybe half
of that [ __ ] that just says [ __ ] this
garbage disposal let that [ __ ] run with
the water
man [ __ ] pumpkin well that was kind of
the to me that was like kind of a bummer
because i feel like this year because a
lot of people didn't go
trick-or-treating and a lot of people
didn't do halloween and stuff
and so i feel like the pumpkin farmers
were all kind of complaining so like
nobody's buying the pumpkins and it's
sad because
you can cook so much like just one
pumpkin
you can get so much [ __ ] food out of
that what this year nobody bought
pumpkins
well it was just like significantly
depleted you know what i mean because
there wasn't as many like halloween
events
i can't believe people buy those things
they carve them and then just throw them
away i don't realize how much food that
is yeah you do all you have to do is
roast them and you scrape all the meat
off and it's just like you can make so
much stuff
it's like squash yeah it just tastes
like squash it's good anything anything
that you can make squash out of you can
you can use the pumpkin yeah for that
it's it's [ __ ] good
i know i love pumpkin i'm i don't care
if that makes me a basic [ __ ]
you don't even like pumpkin spice lattes
you can even use them like a substitute
for mashed potatoes make or
sweet potatoes yeah like yams you don't
use it as a side you can do anything
yeah yeah sophie says squirrels love
them too i bet
yeah probably yeah oh yeah [ __ ] we
should have you know because then
this whole [ __ ] place be overrun with
squirrels and then pookie would be like
trying to kill them all
and tear their heads off so uh all right
so the movie we're talking about today
going back a couple years to 2017
this is one that i heard about a couple
of years ago
i think i first heard about it on ryan
hollinger's channel
he's an irish guy that does like really
he's like a
you know he's he does like these really
long like really in-depth like looks
into
horror movies and thrillers and stuff
and uh so go check his channel out he's
really awesome
so he talked about how this was his
favorite horror movie of 2018
um because it you know it's from 2017 to
come out until a little bit later
and i was very excited to see that hulu
had it so i said well [ __ ] i'm gonna
watch that [ __ ]
so i did and it's called ghost stories
now
it's a british film and it's
sort of an anthology kind of
but not and it's i don't really want to
spoil it because it's got like a really
big twist and i feel like the twist from
what i could determine
is kind of um polarizing like in the
community of
people that have seen this movie like
some people are like oh that was really
awesome or some people were like oh no
that was like i can't believe they like
made that
a twist but i really liked it like i
said i'm not going to spoil with the
twisters even though it's kind of hard
to talk about the movie if i don't
but basically okay so here's the setup
there's this guy
named philip goodman and his job is
that he is like he has like a tv show
where he
debunks psychics and like supernatural
kind of [ __ ]
so they have like a thing at the
beginning where he's debunking like a
faith healer or like a psychic that's on
stage that's pulling like a peter pop
off if you guys don't know who that is
he was that televangelist that
um i think james randy was like kind of
instrumental in bringing
that well he didn't bring him down but
like investigating him where it's like
he would
have all these people fill out prayer
cards like before they went into one of
his readings
and then he had like his wife or
somebody like talking to him over an
earpiece like reading from the
she's like hey you know this person is
sitting here and their kid has cancer or
something like that so
it looked like he was psychic but he was
just getting information from that [ __ ]
i think they made a steve martin movie
that was uh called leap of faith that
was kind of based on him except
a comedy back before people understood
electronics
[Laughter]
a microphone in his ear yeah he just had
and that's all you had to do was like
essentially hack into his into the
frequency and you'd be able to hear what
he was hearing
and that's what james randy did and so
that's kind of what uh
this guy's job is so he goes around like
debunking psychics
now this guy his um
his like hero in his debunking hero
is this guy named charles cameron who
apparently was doing the same kind of
[ __ ] like back in the 70s
so he actually finds out like charles
cameron has disappeared
but he actually finds him at like this
[ __ ] shifty
like holiday camp somewhere like in
[ __ ] i don't know where it is
brighton or somewhere
um and so he goes to see him and the guy
is like grumpy and old
and he's like look all the debunking
[ __ ] you do you suck um
i'm kona over that supernatural totally
exists
and um here are three cases that i came
up with
um in my studies that i could not debunk
and i could not disprove and you need to
go
investigate these and then come back and
you will see that like the supernatural
exists you will see that ghosts exist
so then they go into basically the three
stories so the first story is like about
this guy who is
a night watchman at this old like
abandoned building that used to be like
a women's
uh mental hospital i think or something
like that and um it's just kind of this
creepy thing where he
like keeps seeing like this little girl
and everything
and then he has a thing where he's uh
estranged from his
daughter who has locked in syndrome
which if you don't know what that is
it's like a
it's like a coma but i think they're
kind of like aware of everything that's
going on but they can't move
or anything so there's that kind of
thing then the second case
is about this young kid who's like a
teenager in his early 20s and
i'm not sure what his um
[Music]
what his psychological thing is maybe i
i don't know if he's like maybe has
asperger's or something like that but he
has something or an anxiety uh
kind of thing and he's telling the story
about how
he was coming home late from a party one
night like out in the middle of nowhere
and essentially like
hit the devil with his car like or a
demon or something like that
and now believes that like this demon is
haunting him
and then um so after those two stories
happen
like the debunker guy philip goodman he
he's kind of like look it's like this
doesn't prove anything it's like you
know these people are just seeing what
they want to see which is kind of like a
big theme of the movie like your brain
sees what it wants to say blah blah
and they're like no now you need to go
on to like the third story now the third
story
um is about this guy who's like a a
finance guy or something like that he's
played by uh martin freeman which if you
don't know i i first saw him
from the british version of the office
but he's been on a bunch of other things
in a bunch of other things as well
so he plays this guy and his wife
who's kind of older they're trying to
have a baby and they had to do ivf and
everything and then she got pregnant
and while he while she was in the
hospital like having the baby because
there was like complications
then like some poltergeist [ __ ] started
happening to his house and then
it's kind of like he sees the ghost of
his wife because they all died and
everything
so i can't like i said i can't spoil it
because like i said
it's like an anthology because these
three stories are kind of like distinct
stories
but as the story goes on you're kind of
led to believe that philip goodman the
main character
that maybe some of this is or maybe all
of this is kind of
for his benefit or it's all from his
perspective
that's all i'm gonna say about it so
because at one stage like after the
third story
um and then he goes back to this old
guy's house like charles cameron the guy
that sent him out on this
you know whatever and
um weird [ __ ] starts happening like
the whole thing gets like turned around
like on its head and everything
yeah i'm not saying much about it
because i kind of fell asleep during it
yeah well you yeah you you were watching
something else i think yeah i had
headphones the second movie of the night
and i was watching i started to get real
sleepy i put my headphones on and i was
kind of like in and out of it it looked
good though
it was actually i really really liked it
i didn't really stay awake
it's gonna be um i mean basically when
they made it it
this was actually based on a stage play
uh that came out in 2010
that was uh jeremy dyson and andy
diamond and i think one of those guys
i don't know if he's like a comedian or
something like that but then one of the
guys also works with um
darren brown that uh he's very famous uh
magician mentalist kind of thing in
the uk yeah he said we've seen like some
of his shows and [ __ ] over here too
so that's kind of where the debunking
psychics angle like comes from
um so so the two of them had had this uh
stage play and this is like the movie
version of it
um i really really dug this movie i
thought i can see why
some people might not like the twist
because you'd be like oh geez or
whatever because it's like
you know but because like i said i can't
say too much about it because it'll
spoil what the twist is
but i actually thought it was pretty
[ __ ] good because like i'm watching
the stories and the stories themselves
are like
really creepy like they have like some
really creepy imagery
like and some of the imagery in it
that's creepy is not even like real like
oh
ghost in your face or anything like that
one of the creepiest things to me was
like in the second one with like about
the kid that ran over the devil or
whatever
so when uh philip first goes to this
kid's house for him to like tell him the
story of what happened to him
he goes in the kid's house and he's
basically like
hey here's your parents or everything
like that and then like the kids like
hey mom and dad i'm going upstairs in my
bedroom
and then phillip like looks in the
kitchen and then just like the mom
is just like standing with her back to
the like with her back to the
guy like at the sink and like not moving
and then like they pan over and then the
dad is standing there in the same exact
way just like wearing a suit and stuff
they're just like standing they're not
doing anything
and it like that really like freaked me
like [ __ ] like that like freaks me out
um because it's not really explained
like why that's just like really really
unsettling and there's a lot of that
kind of [ __ ] in there like plus in the
third one with like all the poltergeist
stuff that was happening like in the
nursery and stuff like with the
stuff like rearranging itself into like
configurations and stuff
kind of like it's kind of like what what
i saw except the apparition part
of course you know yeah not that but you
know yeah there are like apparitions and
there are like some jump scary type of
stuff but it's
it's pretty minimal um i feel like the
jump scary stuff is kind of minimal
tammy said those green seeds may have
been pumpkin seeds i think they were
pumpkin seeds maybe they were
i don't know oh yeah yeah yeah okay i
didn't even think about that well then
that makes it even more apropos for like
dumping in
because we i mean we were eating some of
it like one day for like for a snack
because it's just like a big comes in a
big bag of trail mix
and i was like we were like how the
[ __ ] pumpkin and we're like like
pumpkin bread he's like man we should
pour some of that in the [ __ ] pumpkin
yeah yeah i fell asleep because i missed
my old man now
yeah i don't know you did miss your old
man
we get up real early a lot of times
depending
and and pookie's waking us up all
[ __ ] night i think she might be
where's
i want to put a camera on her because i
feel like
like i've always woke up early except
for like one
you know period in my life where i
worked a night shift like i worked from
like 5 30 p.m to 2 a.m
so i didn't usually get to bed until
like 2 or 3 in the morning and then i
would sleep until like 9 or 10 in the
morning
but other than that time period i have
always had to get up really early like
to go to work and i can't
get out of that habit so
it's pretty much i mean this morning i
mean last night like i said we had to
watch two movies because we had to
uh watch the one for the retrospective
and then we had to watch someone for
this show so we were like what and we
started early i think we started at like
6 00
p.m and um by the time the second one
was over and i was really into the
second one too but by the time that was
over i'm like
man i can't stay awake anymore and it
was maybe like nine o'clock
like we're like [ __ ] old people like
drifted off at nine o'clock at night you
know it's ridiculous
and 10 30 i'm like oh man i gotta go to
sleep yeah
you know like i woke up at three and
went back and then woke up at six and
went back to sleep
that cat wakes me up and she when i'm
falling asleep
she checks on me about three times
before i actually fall asleep every 15
minutes she runs up
you going to sleep yeah and then she
leaves and then she comes back she lays
across me and looks in my face
you really going to sleep she sits there
for a few minutes then she jumps off me
i'll be back in a minute 15 minutes
later does it again lays across my chest
she lays across your chest
looks at me in the face you're really
going to sleep
you awake yet that kind of [ __ ] and i
and i'll eventually fall asleep but i
kind of think she does that
all night i suspect yeah i think every
few hours she runs up and checks on me
we need some like i want to get a camera
we're going to put some night vision
camera
yeah because i've played on a show i bet
she [ __ ] with me i've always wanted to
do that because one i suspect that
pookie
is because if she jumps on the bed
because if she's going to jump and check
on me she she jumps on my shin
and then like runs up my whole entire
body like you know what i mean
yeah so i always feel her because she
weighs like 10 pounds so it's like some
10 pound thing falls on you in the night
but i suspect that she might be jumping
up on my nightstand
and just looking at me yeah what i was
saying that might be like half waking me
up i got a feeling that cat's sucking
running across us every couple hours
we're trying to wake us up i think you
guys sleep too long
yeah why can't we go outside and play
with the frogs and then i hear
i hear i hear that both the cats in
there [ __ ] hissing and fighting it
each fighting each other and running
around the house chasing each other
yeah because every now and then you'll
hear me yeah yeah they're like what the
[ __ ] is going on there
because pookie just by herself i said
she maybe weighs 10 pounds it's like she
sounds like a [ __ ] buffalo who hurts
like i heard a buffalo
[ __ ] and then she slings herself like
underneath the chair and it's like
yeah yeah i've also uh heard her [ __ ]
throw herself up
against doors to open them boom
[Laughter]
she makes so much noise for a little bit
yeah i also want it i also want a night
vision camera because i want to catch
beijing
doing her little cargo cult thing with
the babies yeah i want to see
what that what the hell because she does
that pretty can't really catch her
yeah i hear her but it's already it's
already done
it's already occurred it's already
occurred because usually by the time you
hear her because she makes up
kind of noise like in the middle of the
night if you go out there and you see
her it'll she'll just be sitting by the
baby going be like what i don't know i'm
not doing it's not a baby it's a doll
yeah calling babies we call it baby gets
these little dolls and stuff and takes
them out and
and cries to them we don't know what
it's like
oh no it should have a whole bunch of
them laid out in a pattern
they look like someone poultry guys
would do they need to be in a straight
line or they'll be in a circle
if we didn't have cats
maybe you're interpreting it is this a
diamond or is this a random
fan it's [ __ ] weird man really weird
what does this mean okay what is she
doing she's trying to call
she's trying to call something i kind of
think so too
and we might have mentioned this before
but she didn't do it before
yeah she's trying to feed pookie i think
even though they fight yeah i don't know
but they fight because
every time like beijing walks by pookie
pooky's like look at that fluffy butt
i'm gonna jump on it i'm gonna jump on
it
okay so we gotta get back on the thing
we're talking about cats and not talking
about the movie well that's okay
well like i said i can't really say any
more about the movie because it'll spoil
the twist and like the twist is kind of
like a big
thing so i'm gonna say that this is it's
like an
anthology like one kind of in the vein
of like one of the old like british like
amicus ones like the house of dripped
blood or something
but the frame story is more okay
the frame story is a lot more integrated
with the stories
than um is usually the case with these
types of movies that's all i'm gonna say
um so this is uh on hulu like i said
it's from 2017.
uh if you want to watch it i thought it
was very good so if you guys saw
you know tell me what you thought about
it there's actually another one on hulu
from i think that's also from 2017 2018
that i don't want to see for a while so
i might watch that one tonight to review
tomorrow and i guess that'll do it
because i'm
because the pumpkin bread is smelling
really good and it's
calling me all right it's calling me so
i have to go get some pumpkin bread
before it's like
while it's still like warm and yummy all
right so uh we will see you guys again
talk about another movie tomorrow
and uh thanks for dropping bye